certainly been a lot of excitement about  the opportunity to do a standalone Black  Panther based upon the way the character  was set up a civil war civil wars lost  his father coming to this movie you're  seeing him actually deal with the  responsibility of becoming the new king  the most technologically advanced  country on the planet a big function of  how what kind of works staying out of  the spotlight stay in the shadows it's  my responsibility to make sure that  Wakanda doesn't fall into the hands of a  person like you  the amount of responsibility that he has  as a superhero and as a king to meet us  one of the most fun things what happens  now determines what happens to the rest  of the world  [Music]